here's something you probably don't know
as many as one in five veterans suffers
from ptsd
post-traumatic stress disorder is a
leading cause of suicide among vets but
david martin has word of a surprising
treatment that could lead them out of
the dark
i stab myself in the neck and the wrist
with a knife
and um
i just wanted the pain to stop
a series of pulitzer prize-winning
photographs captured the agony of former
marine scott ostrom his life overwhelmed
by ptsd after two tours in iraq
12 years of nightmares panic attacks and
failed relationships
a danger not only to himself
but to others
deep down i was angry so
really i i think i was just looking for
a fight
what were you angry about
i was angry with myself
i felt guilty for
some of the things that i failed to do
when i was overseas failed to do how
i watched my friend burn alive inside of
a humvee
and the fire was too hot and i couldn't
get to him so
um
i felt like i needed to be punished for
that
you're being haunted by your a memory of
something that happened to you rachel
yehuda of mount sinai hospital in new
york has spent 30 years working with
veterans and other victims of ptsd the
standard treatment for ptsd has been
psychotherapy and there are two
medications that are fda approved for
the treatment of ptsd both of which are
antidepressants
how effective is the treatment these
treatments tend not to really solve the
problem for most people but they are
better than nothing
desperate for relief scott ostrom
answered a facebook ad seeking
volunteers for an fda approved trial
using a psychedelic drug called mdma
better known by its street name ecstasy
it really did change my life come on
buddy
in a short period of time in six months
when i first heard about this i thought
to myself how could this possibly be a
good idea
psychedelics were illegal and designated
by our government as being of potential
harm and no medical benefit
then at the annual burning man festival
in nevada she met rick doblin
i knew that mdma was great for ptsd in
1984. domlin heads a psychedelic
research organization called maps and
for decades has been fighting laws which
made psychedelics illegal when we think
now about how many people over the last
50 years could have been
saved from suicide or depression if the
research hadn't been shut down it's a
tragedy
it was not until 2016 that the food and
drug administration authorized phase 3
trials for mdma
the same kind of phase 3 trials covid
vaccines went through to prove they are
safe and effective
the results from the latest phase 3
trial of mdma were just astounding so
these studies have they produce specific
results two-thirds of the people that
were treated with a course of mdma
no longer have ptsd would you call this
a breakthrough i would absolutely call
this a breakthrough what does the fda
think they've designated mdma-assisted
psychotherapy as a breakthrough approach
what does that mean in terms of what you
can do now
well it doesn't mean you can start
taking mdma on your own it means that
the data are so good that let's get this
on a fast track for approval
but life on that fast track costs money
the biggest obstacle really for us was
raising the funds to do the research
because the pharmaceutical companies
were not interested the major
foundations were not interested it was
all too controversial
thank you enter bob parsons a maverick
billionaire who first took psychedelics
three years ago
how much of a difference did
psychedelics make in your life the
quality of my life has increased
immeasurably
never a good student parsons joined the
marines at 17 and was sent to vietnam
a month later he was wounded this is a
picture of me in the
field hospital it was the last he saw of
combat but the war continued to haunt
him i was completely different guy that
came home than the guy that left
the guy that came home
he
had a short temper
never felt like he belonged no matter
where he was or who he was with was it
getting better was it getting worse
i believe it was getting worse somebody
would ask me if i served in vietnam i
started crying
parsons made his fortune from godaddy go
daddy.com
an internet company which he turned into
must-see tv
with risque super bowl ads
now you're a billionaire what are you
going to do with all that money i'm
going to do what i can to get
psychedelics approved for therapeutic
use
parsons has donated more than seven
million dollars to psychedelic research
under the influence of mdma
scott ostrom was able to actually
visualize his inner demons this spinning
black ball started to open itself up to
me
in different layers like an onion
and then each layer
revealed like a new memory and it was
almost like
the layers were just opening and opening
and opening at the center he found a
part of him he calls the bully
it was
a terribly
frightening creature the bully is
basically
the person you had to become in order to
survive two tours in iraq that's right
that's who the marine corps trains you
to be a fighter and a killer
and that's who i had to become to
survive those deployments
with the aid of two psychotherapists he
was able to come to terms with it
after those three mdma sessions i
haven't had a nightmare about the war
since do you
suffer panic attacks anymore no do you
have any thoughts of suicide
no
but like a drunk getting sober he can't
undo all the damage done
all the years lost
you know i spent over a decade
pushing people away and
making my life harder on myself and not
loving myself so
as far as dealing with the combat part
of my ptsd we were successful in that
but
i
i still think i can be a better person i
still think there's room to grow
mdma may be a breakthrough but it's
still a trial drug not likely to be
available to the estimated 1 million
veterans suffering from ptsd
until 2024
what the breakthrough means to me
is that we have a meaningful way to
spend our time now so that we can bring
a new paradigm of care to the people
that need it most it just means that
there's real hope out there that may
really end up being a game changer for
people that have suffered for way too
long
you